John mine
my bad j'envoyais un tweet peut-être
s'il vous plaît demandez à ted de déménager afin que nous puissions
continuer notre vie Je ne suis pas si
excité de le chasser oh
désolé hé tu rentres tôt qui sont
ces filles oh nous  Je suis sur mon homme c'est
Lori c'est Angelique Heavenly dit que tu
dois déménager Je vais t'aider à te
lever là-bas Je promets que j'ai l'air stupide Je
tu sais que tu as l'air pimpant John Je ressemble
à quelque chose que tu donnes à ton enfant quand
tu  dis-lui que grand-mère est
morte ici non je regarde ta serviette
jure devant Dieu de ne pas te regarder drôle d'
affaire j'ai rencontré une fille sympa elle est
caissière
ok d'accord donc c'est ce que nous allons tracer
la ligne
vous